hello this is Adam Smith calling from
the website of the Nobel Prize
hi thank you very much indeed for taking
the call well first of all
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Peace Prize does the prize does
the mean for you to go on it was an
[Music]
exciting proposition value at the
stitches in diadem nakka nakka everybody
now undocumented workers janitors this
very severe ocean require oxygen
osmolarity situation especially known
turnover has entirely stuck here for me
you know I thought that even with
thinking about the experience doing this
work that women who are suffering
you know sexual violence in conflict is
their voice their cries will not desert
and for those small communities are
being persecuted in many corners of the
world that Eric rajala answers but this
you know this price tells me that this
terrible receipts are being heard and
posted this prize will be able to older
women that are suffering from sexual
violence and conflict in this is the
first time the next year that these
communities like mine working we will
not disappear thank you very much indeed
that is a very hopeful message the prize
will bring your work to the attention of
many people what would you like those
people to do for me
justice is important and you know how to
injustice for those women that suffers
from sexual violence and it's just for
them we prevent similar acts like that
and your eyebrows rather hard okay then
walk through 30 milady and I believe
justice is done for these that are worth
fighting for currently that this will
not happen again
I believe the state Commissioner
McCollum has mastered chemical energy
society because I should examine a
second one the radical killer is now in
the red glare isn't a couple of images
with a resolution of the solarium and
how they kidding we hosted we were to
help in this cries we can accomplish
this the message that we've been joking
out about making sure that people accept
each other especially if they're from
different religions different faiths in
that region that they accept each other
and be able to again in peace niche
future thank you very much indeed
one last question um you work so hard at
this where do you get your strength
I welcome unlevel election in a second
using a lot about hydrology and fishes
Islam how to erecting and fish and that
is accessorize Connecticut certain
hydrogen's or inspired like a quarter
net cash card in Jewish people
conversing that Makhachkala mix 2011 ala
coushatta beer and chicken marketing
there's nice fish nice economical some
isn't our but something I want to know
how can happen another nitrogen and and
I'm realizing the reason young so I can
share a cadet captain as objective as
Masha Masha Allah are my muscles in
xanthine one and how I plan to be on a
health charity so I didn't have strength
do you think I have the strength to do
the work that every time I noted and my
community understood the pictures of my
family and my lock features and my
mother of my life simply because we we
believe it differently because simply we
had a different religion and in this
capitalistic cities with the gun
clicking ah - ah - can I throw a shout
out there cousin Jim greatest Harbor
said you know I'm not gonna happen today
city garbage okay I had with him execute
so did the same kind I felt even though
if I leave Iraq in a shuttle in Germany
on the way that would this current world
cities in their connected that this
ideology which can be anywhere and then
it can follow you in the case other
people
thank you very much indeed for speaking
to me and may may I wish you every
success with your mission and also
congratulate you again on the Nobel
Prize
thank you their relative Kherson is very
materia
managing masculine issue I can remember
those values I'm trendy as the new
changes can decimate shows you sort of a
Chanel as photochemical shipping
leadership but you especially like a
luminary salami
um you know I also want I'm very happy
that dr. Denis mukwege B is equal owner
with me and he's mammoth integrity a
good man with his heart and healthy
women and one thing that's been changed
and he deserved it and I pray for him to
win this prize because he really did it
thank you thank you and congratulations
again okay